F: Salut, cette année souvent quand on a parlé de mémoire
on a parlé d'image, on a parlé de visualisation,
mais on a rarement parlé des sons
et aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler des sons
même d'un absolu dans les sons puisqu'on va aussi parler de l'oreille absolue
Je n'ai pas l'oreille absolue
et je ne sais même pas si j'ai la bonne définition de l'oreille absolue et c'est pour ça que j'ai invité Robin
qui lui l'a, et on va pouvoir en discuter ensemble
Générique
*Musique du générique*
F: Robin c'est le Iron Man de la guitare
tu as la guitare de Iron Man mon pote
Merci Robin d'être là, c'est cool
R: Mais merci à toi Fabien
F: Je kiffe le tee-shirt,
R: de m'avoir invité
F: La guitare, toi c'est parfait
Est ce que tu peux nous donner ta définition de l'oreille absolue déjà tu vois
R: Alors déjà l'oreille absolue, il y a beaucoup d'idée reçue, là dessus
c'est à dire que souvent c'est présenté comme... l'oreille Ultime en fait
F: C'est ça, l'oreille des génies
R: Oui c'est ça
F: L'Oreille des génies musicaux
R: Et... alors que non pas du tout l'oreille absolue ça consiste simplement en...
Reconnaître une note dans l'absolue
F: Peu importe que le son vienne d'un instrument de musique ou pas en fait,
c'est, tu entends un son et tu es capable de dire la note
R: C'est ça
F: On a eu un petit soucis de caméra mais on est bon. On est bon
F: Donc l'oreille absolue. L'oreille relative?
R: Alors l'oreille relative ça va être reconnaître une note par rapport à une autre
c'est à dire par exemple si on prends [Joue sur la guitare] un DO ici [joue une autre note]
on va reconnaître que c'est un SOL que c'est une quinte juste
[Joue différentes notes]
R: Ceux qui ont reconnu c'est Superman
F: Ah c'est Man Of Steel
R: Oui c'est Man Of Steel
F: Yes
F: [Chante les notes de Man Of Steel]
Voilà, c'est bon j'ai l'oreille absolue. Je me casse
R: Et tu vas avoir l'oreille harmonique aussi.
L'oreille harmonique c'est ce qui va permettre de reconnaître un accord.
Par exemple,
[Joue plusieurs accord]
Un accord majeur et un accord mineur
F: Qui combine, lui même, plusieurs notes
R: Voilà qui combine plusieurs notes et à ce moment là on va parler de couleur d'accord
F: Alors, je rebondis cher ami sur votre mot "couleur"
parce qu'on a eu une petite conversation intéressante en prenant le café avec Monsieur Robin
où... tu me... tu m'as fait un parallèle à un moment donné
sur les couleurs, par rapport aux notes
R: Je ne le consentis pas si tu veux, ça me vient comme ça viendrai... voilà comme couleur
F: C'est spontannée
F: Et voilà c'est...
R: Tu vois du bleu c'est du bleu
F: Et c'est ça qui est génial
Quand on voit un bleu, n'importe quelle gamme du bleu d'ailleurs, on dit automatiquement c'est un bleu
R: Oui
F: De la même manière tu entends un son, tu vas dire automatiquement c'est telle note
Et euh... et de la même manière, je me disais ça pendant que tu préparais la guitare tout à l'heure
C'est vrai que, je suis incapable de décrire une couleur
c'est à dire que va expliquer, par exemple, à quelqu'un qui a eu... qui a...
qui est non voyant de naissance, va lui expliquer ce qu'est du vert, c'est impalpable c'est pas possible.
et de la même manière tu ne peux pas expliquer ce qu'est un DO... ou un LA ou un LA mineure... dans ta tête.
R: Ouais
F: Ça va être trop compliquer, c'est impalpable.
Il te faut des seuils de référence pour pouvoir expliquer par rapport à quelque chose.
donc ça veut dire, qu'on est censé tous être capable de travailler ce phénomène là.
R: Exactement
F: Euh... d'oreille absolue entre guillemet quoi
R: Exactement, ça je le vois quand je donne des cours à des gamins,
finalement on voit le progrès petit à petit... on développe une certaine oreille.
alors c'est vrai que aujourd'hui on parle, enfin comment dire
L'oreille absolue... c'est pas une fin en soi c'est à dire c'est pas l'oreille forcément musicale
F: Ouais
R: La musique c'est beaucoup d'écoutes, beaucoup de... d'émotions on va dire
oui de ressenti en fait... des choses
F: Ouais
R: C'est ça qui va faire ta musicalité, c'est ça qui va faire, et pas le fait de savoir tes notes
F: Je crois qu'on a un problème, nous, culturel sur le son.
euh...on le délaisse alors que si on travaillait dès le départ
juste notre capacité à reconnaître.
Vous savez quand on est petit à la maternelle,
on fait des jeux, genre
Moi je me souviens de ce jeu là
il y avait un bac rouge, un bac jaune et un bac bleu
et on avait des objets et il fallait qu'on les range au bonne endroit
donc un citron *tac* ça va dans le bac jaune parce que le citron est jaune
et c'est comme ça qu'on fait l'apprentissage des couleurs
Si on faisait la même chose avec... avec les notes de musiques
avec les sons
R: Oui ça serait acquis complètement
F: Voilà, on habituerait directement le cerveau à avoir son vrai seuil de référence
à avoir sa boucle... ces boucles sonores qui tournent quelque part dans la tête
et qui nous servirez pour comparer et on ne se poserait plus la question
la même manière que
le LA on va le définir. Il y a le LA majeur, le LA mineur, le LA septième, le LA tout ce que tu veux
Il y a le jaune pâle, le jaune foncé, le jaune poussin, le jaune tout ce que tu veux
donc on serait capable aussi de trouver un peu ses nuances
mais, ouais, il faudrait faire un apprentissage complet dès le départ
Moi j'expliquais à Robin un truc.
Je fais ma pipelette
Je suis désolé, c'est ma chaîne *rire*
ce que j'expliquais à Robin tout à l'heure c'est que, souvent je vous parle d'image,
moi je vais au delà des images en fait
en général je fonctionne en 3 dimensions
donc j'ai une situation
j'ai les images de cette situation, j'ai l'émotion, j'ai le temps qui passe, j'ai la chaleur, j'ai les odeurs
j'ai... les sensations je crois que je vous l'ai dis
j'ai les sons qui arrivent. Voilà je cumule avec tout ça
Et en fait, pour les sons
j'utilise des sons de ma mémoire, de ma vie, tu vois.
le coucou qu'il y avait chez mon grand père, tu vois des trucs comme ça.
Mais si j'étais capable de maîtriser, en fait, les notes comme je le souhaite
je suis sûr que je gagnerai encore plus dans mes techniques de mémorisation
R: Je pense qu'il y a une carte à jouer
F: Ouais
F: Toi tu parles de ce genre de chose sur le site ou tu vas de ce genre de chose?
R: Oui je vais en parler, justement, oui.
Il va y avoir un petit article
F: Yes c'est bien comme ça on peut le relire à tête reposée
N'oubliez pas dans la description, il y a le lien vers le site de Robin.
Donc ça veut dire que si moi à l'aveugle je te fais une note, tu sais me dire ce que je fais?
R: Oui c'est ça
F: On essaie ou pas?
R: On essaie
F: Je peux te prendre la guitare?
R: Oui
F: Alors là on est pas du tout dans l'apprentissage, là on est dans mon kiff
Bon alors... l'idée c'est ça je te fais et tu nous dis ce que c'est?
R: Tu veux qu'on mette un bandeau devant mes yeux?
F: Nooon, on te fait une confiance absolue
F: Alors attention c'est parti
je commence gentil en faisant du note à note
[Fabien joue]
R: DO
F: euh... alors attends c'est... *rire*
R: Oui c'est DO
Normalement c'est 3ème case de la corde de LA
F: SI, DO... oui c'est ça
*rire*
F: Parce que moi il faut que je réfléchisse en fait
R: Mais après on peut entendre le timbre et moi comme je connais bien la guitare je sais exactement à quel endroit tu jouais
F: ah oui c'est ça.
F: Avec l'octave et tout
R: Souvent les gamins sont impressionnés
F: Ils ont droit
F: Ah ben oui tiens alors dis moi où j'ai mon doigt
Put*** cette phrase est tellement chelou les mecs
Dis moi où j'ai mon doigt
[Fabien joue]
R: Alors là tu as pas ton doigt sur la guitare, tu as fais le MI à vide.
[Fabien joue encore]
F: J'ai fait un piège [continue de jouer]
bien sûr, alors ça marche ce qu'il a dit
c'est comme si j'avais fait le MI à vide puisque je suis sur le MI de la corde précédente.
R: Ah ouais
F: Mais c'est la même chose en fait
[Fabien continue de jouer]
R: Ah oui tu veux vraiment jouer, ouais, ah j'aurai pas cru
R: Il m'a eu !
F: OK
F: Mais c'est bien joué puisque que c'est exactement la même note
euh...
F: [chantant] Où est mon doigt??
[Fabien joue]
R: Alors SI bémol, alors je dirai 3 cases de la corde de SOL
*Fabien s'arrête de jouer et réfléchi*
F: Non pas du tout, c'était un LA dièse
R: Ben...
*Fabien Rigole*
R: Il est bon, il est bon.
*Rire de Robin et Fabien*
F: Put*** j'ai réfléchi pour faire la vanne tu as vu
alors pour ceux qui connaissent pas la musique un LA dièse et un SI bémol c'est la même chose en fait
F: Est ce que je tente 2-3 accords et tu trouves l'accord.
R: Allez ça marche
F: Donc là on est sur l'oreille harmonique?
R: On reste plutôt sur l'oreille harmonique, oui exactement
F: Oreille harmonique, oreille harmonique c'est parti
[Fabien joue]
R: C'est un RÉ majeur
F: Yehhh
[Fabien joue]
R: RÉ mineur
F: Bien sûr
[Fabien joue]
R: MI majeur
F: Oui
[Fabien joue]
R: MI mineur
F: OUI en plus je ne joue pas toutes les cordes
des fois je me plante alors bien joué
alors attention c'est parti
[Fabien joue]
F: C'est les Frères misère pour ceux qui connaissent
[Fabien continue de jouer]
F: C'était le groupe de Mano Solo
[Fabien continue de jouer et se stoppe]
R: RÉ mineur, SI bémol majeur, LA majeur,
F: Ah mais oui c'est énorme
Alors attention nouvelle difficulté
J'ai trouvé une dernière idée pour le mettre, une dernière fois, au défi
euh... je prends un son
de n'importe où, du fin fond de ma tête, je le siffle
tu me dis la note que c'est.
et une fois que tu as dis la note que c'est pour me prouver que c'est bon, tu... tu... tu nous la joue. Ça marche?
R: On vérifie sur la guitare. Yes
F: OK on fait ça
F: Euh... *Siffle*
R: Ça fait plutôt FA dièse
[Robin le joue à la guitare]
F: AH put*** c'est ouf
C'est ça l'oreille absolue mon pote
R: Un petit peu plus aigu en vrai
*Fabien siffle*
R: Alors ça s'est un RÉ
[Robin le joue à la guitare]
F: Put*** c'est bon ça.
Alors est ce que je sais encore faire ça
*Siffle avec ses mains*
R: Alors,
R: Je dois deviner l'animal c'est ça?
*Rires de Fabien et Robin*
F: C'est ça Mec
R: Donc c'est DO, MI bémol, RÉ, MI bémol, RE
F: Tu nous le fais
[Robin le joue à la guitare]
R: Non non.
Non c'était MI, RÉ
F: C'est ça
[Robin le joue à la guitare]
F: Put*** en fait je suis un compositeur de génie mec.
il me fallait juste un mec comme toi
pour après exploiter mon génie
R: Un producteur là, il achète direct
F: Quel est le mot de la fin, de tout ça Robin
R: Le mot de la fin, c'est que...
ça peut se travailler en fait.
F: C'est que ça peut se bosser.
R: Voilà.C'est que tout à chacun peut développer l'oreille absolue
F: Ouais
R: Alors forcément, dans tout les domaines chacun va avoir plus ou moins de pré-disposition ou pas.
C'est comme partout
F: Ça c'est un discours que je tiens pour la mémoire, ça par exemple, ouais !
R: Ouais, ben typiquement j'avais essayé ton tour de carte,
savoir reconnaître, dans l'ordre, les cartes rouges et noires
F: Ah retenir les rouges et les noires ouais
R: Et ouais j'avais trouvé ça tellement complètement bluffant parce que...
parce qu'au bout d'1h30 j'y arrivais quoi.
F: Ah oui
R: Enfin...
F: Put*** moi je suis tellement ravi quand je sais qu'il y en a qui essaie, qui s'auto-bluff eux même à réussir
[Robin joue un petit morceau]
F: Bon allez voir le site de toute manière,
puisque tu vas faire un nouveau billet là dessus
R: Oui
F: un nouvel article dessus
dans la description, toujours, mais je l'ai déjà dit tellement de fois mon gars.
[Robin joue un petit morceau]
F: Et tu as aussi une chaîne internet, je vous invite aussi à la découvrir
je vous mettrai ça peut être pas dans la fiche...
également dans la description c'est plus simple. Tout est au même endroit c'est mieux
[Robin joue un petit morceau]
F: J'espère que ça vous a plu et si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas vous pouvez liker et vous abonner
et rendez vous demain à 17h
Ciao !